[Música]
qué fue lo primero que pensaste esta
mañana cuando te viste en frente al
espejo
alguien pensó algo negativo
alguien ni siquiera se vio sabía que el
70% del resultado que uno obtiene cada
día depende de ese primer pensamiento
con relación a uno mismo
si no sabían o no
ah bueno pues si ese primer encuentro
íntimo que tenemos con nosotros mismos
determina
como nos vamos a relacionar en el afuera
en el planeta todo está lleno de vida
todo tiene una frecuencia de vibración
somos energía el cuerpo es nuestro
vehículo es un instrumento es como un
instrumento musical y ese primer
pensamiento que tiene sobre ti es la
forma en la que tú afina su instrumento
y con el que vas a salir a relacionarte
con todo afuera con tu trabajo tus
emociones y hacer la vida en resonancia
te va a responder de la misma manera
cómo funciona esto
hoy sabemos gracias a la neurociencia
que el pensamiento produce las emociones
justamente por eso somos lo que pensamos
si a esto le sumamos lo que comemos todo
lo que alimentamos a nuestros sentidos
la tristeza el estrés el poco ejercicio
criticar maldecir quejarse estamos
construyendo una bomba
y ciudad para nuestros tres campos de
salud cuerpo mente y espíritu y por lo
general lo que hacemos es siempre
responsabilizar algún factor externo de
nuestra situación actual con lo cual
dejamos a nuestra capacidad de
discernimiento completamente fuera de
nuestra toma de decisiones
reflexionemos un poquito cómo puede
alguien esperar que en su vida haya
salud prosperidad y alegría si en este
primer encuentro contigo mismo cada
mañana no te tomas el tiempo de observar
te
de agradecer para darte un deseo de buen
día
como seguramente muchas de nuestras
nuestras de nuestros pensamientos son de
manera inconsciente tendemos a repetir
quizá muchos miedos heredados miedos que
a veces reconocemos como propios porque
tienen que ver más bien con la mayoría y
azul que asumimos que forman parte de lo
que sentimos sin darnos el tiempo
necesario de detenernos respirar
para poder afinar nuestro instrumento
afinar nuestro vehículo y entonces poder
decidir caminar
en el amor
la vida
necesita de un propósito para vivirse y
solo puede vivirse de dos maneras en el
camino del amor o el del miedo el camino
del amor entendido como un proceso
determinado racional deliberado empático
contigo mismo y con todo lo demás por tu
prosperidad por el bienestar por la
armonía claro que para ese camino hay
que hacer uso de una energía mental hay
que tomar un tiempo para respirar y
tomar una decisión proceso cognitivo se
llama se tiene que pagar un peaje que no
todos están dispuestos a pagar
evitar el pago
te lleva frecuentemente a tomar el otro
camino el del miedo el instantáneo el
inmediato en el que respondemos sin
pensar precisamente porque estamos
acostumbrados
al no darnos el tiempo de detenernos
para saber qué es lo que realmente
estamos sintiendo
hace muchos años yo les quiero compartir
tuve la oportunidad gracias a una
experiencia importante de empezar a
entender ya diferenciar todo este
proceso del discernimiento y eso es a lo
que les quiero invitar hoy a que decidan
tomar el camino del amor cuando tenía
unos 10 años fui a hacer las audiciones
para una obra de teatro que en ese
momento era muy popular con un grupo
infantil que era el más famoso en ese
momento y una de las pruebas era de
imagen y consistía en parar a todas las
niñas y niños hacia alineados al final
del escenario digamos al borde casi del
escenario para que desde en medio de las
butacas de ese lugar una señora que era
el asistente de producción pudiera
gritar nosa boca de jarro a cada uno de
nosotros en frente de todos lo que
pensaba de nuestra imagen
ay por dios pero si tú eres un monumento
al barro que no tienes espejo en tu casa
bájate niño no no es una albóndiga con
patas como crees que vas a poder bailar
en esta obra quitate vanessa otra vez
que estés aquí tú eres un error de la
naturaleza no lo entiendes no debiste
haber nacido
yo ni siquiera sabía que eso podía ser
un insulto
luego de shock
de esa sentencia y de la furia que
provocó en mi familia cuando les conté
lo que había pasado pues tuve que
prohibirles que fueran a reclamar algo
porque yo tenía temor de tener algún
escándalo en mi incipiente carrera
profesional y a pesar de que pertenecía
a una familia que siempre me había
demostrado su amor lo cual es una
evidencia
esa sentencia ajena me hizo mella en mi
subconsciente
empiece a hablar para adentro me comí la
voz
y perdí un poco de la alegría y del
ímpetu que siempre me habían
caracterizado seguí tomando clases de
actuación de baile de canto seguí
estudiando e iba a todas las audiciones
cada vez con más ganas me entregaba más
que nunca pero por dentro rogaba que
ojalá nadie se fuera a dar cuenta que yo
era un error de la naturaleza
porque aunque sabía que no lo era algo
dentro de mí lo pensaba
y así fueron pasando los meses sin que
tuviera yo un resultado positivo
obviamente hasta que a un buen día me
morí
literal clínicamente morir
un año después de esta sentencia que
impactó profundamente en mi vida morí
tuve la experiencia de lo que conocemos
como muerte clínica fue en el año de
1985 un mes después de un terremoto que
sacudió a la ciudad de mexico
mi familia y yo vivíamos en una zona
céntrica de la ciudad y pues como podrán
imaginarse todo ese proceso fue no solo
de miedo fue aterrador doloroso fue muy
duro
justamente un mes después del terremoto
estando yo en el salón sentí como la
energía empezaba a abandonar mi cuerpo
alcancé a decirle a mi compañera de al
lado creo que me voy a desmayar
me desmayé el director de la escuela me
llevó al hospital de urgencias más
cercano y según le dijeron a mi mamá yo
llegué en estado de coma y morí de un
paro respiratorio por dos minutos
cabe señalar que nunca me he sentido
mejor en la vida que cuando estuve
muerto
seguramente en este punto usted está
diciendo de qué está hablando esta
señora como de que se murió un paro
respiratorio pues como así fue
precisamente yo en ese momento lo que
experimenté fue como si una como una
aspiradora gigante enorme me succionará
completamente no vi pasar toda mi vida
ni nada sino colores nada más a los
lados hasta que llegué a un limbo blanco
como una especie de huevo donde como era
arriba era abajo y a los lados donde
estaba completamente sola y en un estado
de plenitud que no puede explicarse con
palabras
de pronto a lo lejos escuché muy quedo
una voz que decía tenemos que levantar
el acta y avisarle a los papás porque
esta niña se nos fue
solo en ese momento entendí que no
estaba soñando
pensé inmediatamente en mi familia
voltee hacia donde creí que había
escuchado esa voz y en realidad lo que
hice fue tener como una visión desde
arriba en cine le llamamos un top shot
lo que pude ver fue como lo recuerdo una
cama pequeñita conmigo en ella los
doctores haciendo maniobras de
resurrección un monitor chiquito donde
alcancé a ver una rayita verde que hacía
pis
y largo
pensar en mi madre en mi hermano de mi
papá en cómo iba a romperles el corazón
si no regresaba me parecía me parece
injusto sentía que algo no estaba bien
sobre todo teniendo nos tanto amor y esa
fue la palabra mágica
esa fue la visa que me permitió volver a
mi encuentro plaza en el amor sentía que
me soltaban desde arriba y de no tener
ningún signo vital me incorporé
rápidamente con el corazón a todo lo que
daba luego del susto
los doctores pensaron que me iba a dar
un ataque cardíaco pero no lograron
estabilizar me y cuando me entregaron el
mama jamás supieron decirle
qué fue lo que pasó ni porque me fui ni
porque regrese y hasta la fecha sostengo
que lo primero fue por miedo y lo
segundo fue por amor
ustedes sabían que el cerebro segrega la
droga más poderosa que se conoce en la
tierra justo antes de morir según la
neurociencia esto sucede para
permitirnos superar el miedo que implica
desprendernos de la materia de los
afectos
de ahí saqué la bromita esta de que
estando yo en aquel estado pues nunca me
sentí mejor en la vida que cuando estuve
muerto
una prueba medio de mal gusto pero
finalmente lo que yo entendí
es que tal vez si todos tuviéramos una
experiencia cercana a la muerte
podríamos valorar mucho más
profundamente cada instante cada segundo
ya todos los que tenemos cerca mientras
estamos aquí
pero bueno pues finalmente
algo de eso que resonaba en mi
subconsciente
el camino del miedo se ha de haber
quedado algún paisaje de esa voz
que tiro esa sentencia funesta porque
después de esta muerte clínica
experimenté crisis disociativas que
fueron diagnosticadas como petit man
pequeño mal es una especie de epilepsia
que no es compulsiva que hace que el
cerebro
descargue más electricidad de lo normal
y se desconecta el cuerpo de la mente
justo
justo como el mismo estado en el que me
encontraba cuando tuve la muerte clínica
esto me sucedió cada 23 años a lo largo
de 10 años el neurólogo me recetó un
medicamento que tenía que tomar de por
vida y me negué a hacerlo algo dentro de
mí mi intuición me decía que las
respuestas estaban adentro que tenía que
encontrarlas ahí así pasaron 10 años en
la cuarta crisis que tuve al abrir los
ojos y ver a mi familia ya mis amigos
alrededor de mí angustiados justo lo que
yo quería evitar los diez años atrás
cuando decidí volver me armé de valor le
dije al doctor que quería que en ese
momento me hicieran los estudios
neurológicos necesarios para demostrarle
que yo no tenía nada en el cerebro se
resiste un poco no me cree yo lo
convencí hicimos dos estudios y
efectivamente no había nada en mí
y justificará clínicamente lo que me
pasaba para entonces yo ya tenía alguna
sospecha de las carreteras por las que
yo andaba previamente en cada uno de
esos episodios hablé con mi madre con mi
familia tratamos de hacer ese recorrido
de esos 10 años y efectivamente confirme
mi teoría era el miedo siempre fue el
miedo
así que decidí aceptar frente a mi
familia ya mis amigos que cada vez que
me desconectaba era porque no tenía la
capacidad o no me sentía capaz de
resolver alguna situación y el miedo me
terminaba haciendo que me desconectar
luego de eso me sentí muy liberada
acepté ir a terapia empecé a estudiar
mucho leía muchísimo siempre me ha
gustado leer sobre todo temas que me
ayuden a comprender ya conocerme mejor a
mí misma pero lo más importante de este
proceso es que aprendí a respirar desde
entonces no he vuelto a tener ni una
sola crisis y puedo presumir que tenga
una salud y una capacidad de
recuperación sorprendentes también he
podido construir una carrera sólida y
exitosa aunque
con estar por lo regular esa
inestabilidad rápidamente podría
volvernos a conducir al camino del miedo
pero gracias al aprendizaje previo
en las otras veces que puse que tomé el
camino de miedo puse en práctica el
valor para enfrentarlo y gracias a eso
me di cuenta que la inestabilidad te
obliga a salir del círculo de confort te
obliga a desarrollar otras habilidades
que ni siquiera sabías que tenías te
ayuda a reconocer el poder de tu fuerza
interior pero sobre todo la experiencia
de la muerte clínica y del rechazo
de forja el carácter y te ayuda a
entender de una manera mucho más
profunda el dolor y las necesidades de
los otros y entonces fue cuando encontré
el verdadero y mayor propósito de mi
vida armonizar con los demás
desde hace 20 años me dedico a diversas
causas sociales y humanitarias ya todo
lo que resuena en mi interior ayudar a
otros es ayudarme a mí misma
saber del poder que existe cuando
armoniza con alguien por una causa
específica en este camino del amor a la
vida es el mejor antidepresivo existe
entonces cómo me gustaría compartirles
de una manera muy sencilla y muy
práctica herramientas que les pueden
servir para qué
y empiecen a discernir por qué camino
quieren transitar si por el del amor o
por el del miedo
lo primero que hay que hacer es checar
el olor hace que el equipo el motor
verdad lo que viene siendo el
instrumento afinar lo viéndonos al
espejo con una sonrisa de verdad honesta
acompañándonos
lo segundo es el aceite el agua eso
quiere decir que tenemos que cuidar todo
lo que consumimos no solamente por la
boca frutas verduras líquido suero
evitar la carne roja de preferencia no
sólo por su salud también por el
calentamiento global y eso de comer
cadáver no es precisamente muy amoroso
priorizados
digo el amazonas nos lo está recordando
lamentablemente
también tenemos que cuidar lo que
escuchamos sobre todo el sistema
eléctrico tiene que ver con alejarnos de
las personas tóxicas dejar de criticar
nunca compararse no existe absolutamente
nadie igual a ti compararse es una total
pérdida de tiempo es mejor rodearte de
personas positivas que saben encontrar
soluciones a los problemas y no al revés
el perdón el perdón es una vía de
retorno inequívoca al camino del amor
empezando por el perdón a uno mismo y
luego a los otros y aunque te tardes
mucho en poder decirlo con que lo
sientas de verdad en tu corazón funciona
sobre todo lo más importante es que
siempre tengan en cuenta que si por
alguna razón se desvía y agarran el
camino del miedo les agarra la tormenta
hay baches fallas mecánicas desviaciones
se les va a acabar la gasolina y no
tienen dinero para pagar
orillas
eso es lo mejor que pueden hacer
orillarse a esperar que pase la tormenta
en lugar de acelerar y arremeter contra
todo lo que se disponga enfrente el
simple hecho de tomarse un momento para
orillarse y respirar ya es optar por el
camino del amor pueden ponerse a hacer
una lista en ese momento de todo lo que
si tienen de todo lo que si funciona
tanto en su cuerpo como en su vida
familiar y laboral y si por alguna muy
extraña razón nada de esto funciona pues
entonces pueden poner a revisarse
haciendo una lista todo lo que se les ha
repetido constantemente a lo largo de la
vida y que ustedes pueden si deciden
pagar la cuota del discernimiento
transformar para lograr la empatía la
prosperidad y la salud entonces
mañana cuando se despierten se paren
frente al espejo
deciden sonreír sé de verdad
reconozcan sí
sepan que tienen la capacidad de optar
por el camino del amor o por el camino
del miedo y en el camino del amor los
resultados se ven inmediatamente
así que por la noche mañana yo sé
y seguramente muy contentos se observan
su pensamiento van a poder decir que
hicieron decidió una experiencia única e
inolvidable van a poder decir que somos
lo que pensamos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]